i was really interested in what it would
mean for
the way people access education to
change
[Music]
eli bildner thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders it is
such a pleasure to have you here
it is a pleasure to be here thanks so
much for having me where are you calling
from
oakland california california wonderful
well i'm in southern california so
definitely not too far
and but i'm originally now situated in
palo alto so eli
20 minutes is not going to do nearly
enough justice for
for everything that i want to cover from
a yale to stanford mba
to early employees coursera chan
zuckerberg initiative
a and bloomberg philanthropies working
on education and housing
oh my god um where do we even start
eli where do we start um
i don't know man you tell me all right
let's start
from growth of tech
move to philanthropy and then let's talk
about
this non-linear nature of your career
and because just before we started this
we started talking about this idea that
you know today
people don't have to choose a linear
path so
you know talk to me about being an early
employee at coursera
andrewing is one of a role model of mine
and talk to you a little bit about what
you were doing there and the growth that
you helped lead
yeah totally uh andrew is a great guy in
fact one of the
everyone's got these sort of early
embarrassing early career memories and i
wasn't so young when i was at coursera
but uh
andrew i traveled with andrew to china a
couple times to
as we were trying to build up business
there i forgot to mention that
yeah and i said this background in china
um and yeah i can talk about that in a
second
but um but i i was having a little bit
of a tough time emotionally just not
sure about what i was doing and i was
having dinner with andrew and i just
kind of like broke down
crying i was sitting there with andrew
and oh
china and he was like comforting me and
trying to like so he's a very he's a
very he's a really
caring and sweet guy and a great leader
and obviously uh
uh a like incredible thinker but um i
had a very
fun sort of personal moment with him or
really respect him just as well then i
can now share that one of my life goals
is to have a crying session with andrew
ing
there we go well it can happen there is
hope for you yet
um but yeah so i mean maybe to connect
uh the
career piece to my experience at corsair
piece i
ended up taking a job at coursera early
on
really not without much kind of strategy
behind it i was really interested in
what it would mean for the way people
access education
to to change i've been involved in
starting in the very early stages in
online coding boot camp and
um and uh one thing i didn't appreciate
coming to coursera is that an early
stage company where there's so much
growth
like really you end up dictating your
role as
much as the company does and i came in
with this experience having worked in
china
and um really a couple months after i
joined
the corsair was starting to think about
are there opportunities for us in china
it turned out that i was really the only
one at the company who had
um business development and partnership
experience in in china and so i was and
you speak mandarin
absolutely mandarin maybe more fluently
at the time
and i was tapped to kind of help project
manage this effort and that then became
a big part of my role so
um you know it's definitely a good i
think
something i try to share with people who
are thinking about kind of early stage
career stuff
whenever you come into a role you know
think about what is in your portfolio
even if it's not something that was in
the job description you signed up for
you know they're probably particularly
at that stage of a company there are a
lot of opportunities to
uh to bring bring that that stuff to
bear so i came to coursera and then um
i was there uh from 2013
through late 2015 and then went to
stanford to do an mba and
saw coursera grow from you know 40
people 35 40 people to
probably 200 and um really interesting
time in the in the company and uh
in the world and then um both after
coursera i had done some work in
philanthropy before but
um sort of have since graduated business
school have worked more in
uh nonprofits and philanthropy and um
yeah i'm happy to talk about pros and
cons of those two very different worlds
um but but that i've seen both sides of
that
how do you go from seeing a great
company growing so fast
a lot of it under also your initiatives
and then
you're going to a business school which
inherently built school it's
business and you know a lot of the a lot
of the business school classes
uh you know so i i i really hope one day
i'll be able to do that as well yeah i
heard about the touchy-feely class at
the gsb
and and all these different experiences
it doesn't seem like they're guiding
necessarily for philanthropy and for
non-profits
where did that even come from
yeah i mean there are probably i don't
know fewer than five people in my
class of 400 who went into nonprofits
um right operating nonprofits so not a
huge focus
although there's a lot at stanford
around social innovation and yeah
there's there's a lot of good exposure
there
um but it's it's not part of the culture
and part of the ether but one thing that
i learned
um it at coursera that that has stuck
with me is um
it's it's you know companies love to
talk about their social mission and
their impact and we're a mission-driven
company and like
you know i think truth be told a lot of
the time that
if i can say this on the show
like it's like it's more marketing
thank you anything and um like i am
i i i work in a community non-profit now
but i'm also like
i think there's nothing wrong with
running a successful business that's
serving customers and serving employees
well and how you run it really matters
and you know you don't need to dress it
up with this whole like you know
or mission driven you know fintech
company working on payment solutions
like yeah i'm sure it's good for the
world but like you know just
own like you're a great company there's
nothing wrong with that so anyhow
what i came to believe through my work
at kind of mission-driven companies i
really respect coursera is that
um if you're a for-profit and
particularly venture-backed company you
know you're always going to be migrating
towards your highest
highest growth and highest margin
opportunities and at coursera that meant
like
corsair has never been going to be a
company that was focused on serving the
most vulnerable
people in the world it's just not what
it was built to do it was built to scale
really quickly
through venture capital and and through
technology
and
and migrate toward the best business
opportunities for the company which have
turned out to be
in uh corporate learning and development
and in
um in traditional degree programs i
think that's great i believe
i i really believe in what coursera is
doing in the world i'm really proud of
having been a part of the company i
love the people there but um it's not
enough that you know
our our economy does not solve
necessarily
um for the problems of the most
traditionally underserved and most
vulnerable in the population that's just
the fact so i knew
coming out of my experience at corsair
that i wanted to think more
and work more on anchor on a population
as opposed to anchoring on a business
model and
non-profits are really good at that i
love it
yeah no yeah i i think i think it's
incredible and it's
i think this ad this take on impact and
and what really needs to be solved i
think that's
that's really it's really inspiring but
then you go and you
actually join some of the most notable
organizations in the world for for this
type of work you
tell me a little bit about this chen
zuckerberg initiative and what you were
doing there and then the bloomberg
philanthropy yeah
i've always been a big fan of trying to
you know create your own career
opportunities and
um and so much of it just have to do
timing and
i during my mba summer as thinking about
what to do
i got connected from a friend and a
mentor to someone who was basically
the kind of chief of staff or interim
media of um
mark zuckerberg and priscilla chan's
philanthropy which hadn't launched then
and she was helping them stand it up and
i said because it was just starting back
then
they're just starting yeah it became
their first turn um
and uh um i think yeah i've always been
drawn to kind of these early stage
uh experiences but um but i think um
philanthropy you know each each sector
i've been involved in whether it's
businesses whether it's philanthropy
whether it's operating non-profits they
all have an important role and one thing
that's very
um powerful about philanthropy is it's
convening power it's agenda setting
power it's sort of like the media in
that way and that
um it's remarkable how little money it
takes
to uh change a conversation or to create
a conversation
um and so i've been really interested
in so like as an example um
particularly with public actors so state
governments local governments um even
the federal government
there's so little and even companies you
know very
very few companies organizations um
policy actors have discretionary money
just laying around
and so um the if you know if you're one
of these actors and you want to try
something really new
you really have very few places to turn
and philanthropy is one of them
and so you know even if you're so just
to give you a specific example i was
working with bloomberg philanthropies
evaluating a bunch of different programs
that they might invest in to spur
investment in career and technical
education so helping
students enter mostly non-degree
pathways that would help equip them with
skills
um the state of delaware was looking to
do something really different with how
they structured
career and technical education and uh
they were looking for funding to do it
and so i went down there
to to kind of understand what they were
thinking
um they'd asked for you know a few
million dollars now the state of
delaware
their entire budget for k-12 i don't
know what it is off the top of my head
but it's
um it's it's certainly not hundreds of
millions of dollars
um but for a grant request of three
million dollars
they brought out the governor a senator
um you know a ceo of a major company
like that is what the pro the promise of
a few million dollars of discretionary
capital
could unlock wow and so if you're a
funder you have this unbelievable
um you know everyone's going to answer
your call and it's a tremendous power
and privilege that comes with a lot of
responsibility in my mind
but um but if you're someone like you
don't have millions of dollars to get
away
um it makes working plan to be
interesting because if you can help
funders um channel their energy
productive ways like you really do have
a good shot of
changing um conversations and setting
agendas
wow no that's that's that's insane and
then so then you move on to
to bloomberg and do you do something
similar over there
as what you did with the chen zuckerberg
initiative
largely with chan zuckerberg initiatives
i was focused on helping them think
about how they might improve housing
affordability in california and
particularly in the bay area
and then at bloomberg my work was more
around
uh higher education and career education
pathways
but similar kind of philanthropic
advising which is just it's one of these
things you know we've gone back to the
thread we we started before the
interview
around career that you know yep
sometimes you just
learn that you have a skill set or that
you know you kind of end up in a network
and then building a portfolio of
projects around that can be really
rewarding so for me it's
part of that has just been getting to
advise different philanthropies
on how they spend their money and what
prior projects they pursue
so what is concourse education what i
believe you're worrying
i believe the locals understand your
drive course yeah
so concourse is a non-profit that i
co-founded about three years ago
that was my first take at starting an
operating nonprofit and were a
college program that helps particularly
low-income working adults in california
earn an accelerated low-cost bachelor's
degree
wow so you're you're helping you're
helping them actually achieve the degree
and how do you actually go about doing
that
so we have a um our
headline goal is to dramatically
simplify the college experience for
working adults who are
you're competing uh for their attention
with kids with
work with um all the complications of
life and particularly for people who
might be working
more than one job or low age jobs and so
you know they don't have time to be on
the phone for two hours with the
financial aid office or try to figure
out what forms to file or
you know if they need academic help to
figure out you know the 10 different
places they might go to get it like
college needs to be designed for them
and so that's what we've done we
basically redesigned the college
experience to really serve that student
population
and we have done that by
partnering with two accredited
universities so we're standalone 51 c3
nonprofit
we have a kind of white label-ish
partnership with these universities
where we
essentially write off their
accreditation and their access to
financial aid
to um again create this better college
experience for for working students
eli over all these years working with
nonprofits trying to solve really
meaningful issues i mean these are not
simple issues to solve yeah and you know
it's one thing to say like okay i'm
gonna go do a startup that
you know makes you a better runner with
a device or whatever it's another thing
to say okay i'm gonna tackle
this a problem of low-income people
trying to
attain a college education while going
through the different adversities that
life has to offer
i i'd love to sort of pick your brain
over the last few minutes that we have
what are some of your earned seeks over
this non-profit sector
about what does it take to go and really
challenge these
these big big problems yeah it's a great
question
um i think one is just right-sized
expectations like
you know you're not nonprofits you're
not going to change the world in
two years um they're really slow build
organizations and for a couple reasons
one is the problems as you reference
they're really intractable these are
hard problems to solve um two uh
you know almost definitionally they sort
of are non-market problems or
there's market failure so you're kind of
you're running against headwinds
um and then three um in terms of like
what is the
what is the lifeblood that keeps
nonprofits going obviously it's
philanthropic capital and
um even for an earned revenue nonprofit
like us where we actually
earn money from our services we still
need philadelphia capital to grow
and philanthropy is just so different
from vc so
just to give you a sense of what that
looks like in practice with vc you know
if you're uh
you know associated vc firm you're
you're looking for deals where you know
it's a 10x a 20x 100x um that's gonna
make your portfolio work
um you know if you're asking for money
for from a philanthropy they're a very
different orientation first of all
it's not so clear what a 10x or 100x is
so it's more than the impact for the
whole conversation is centered more
around impact rather than
more around return and more on return
than in return but
a program officer is not necessarily
incentivized to go for the riskiest
proposition
because even if it does pay off paying
off could take place over 10 to 20 years
and things that go really badly go
really badly in like six to 12 months
so so just from like an incentive
perspective philanthropy is not
incentivized to
uh to really do super risky things at
the same time
philanthropy very reasonably because
nonprofits are not
you know most nonprofits are not on a
track to become self-sustaining on
earned revenue
you know if you're a philanthropy you
don't want to set up a non-profit with a
5 million
annual budget in year one and then year
two they have that cliff where it's like
if i we don't raise five million dollars
we're dead
so nonprofits the way they work is
they're constantly
we're constantly raising our next month
of runway all the time
and what this means from a resourcing
perspective is it's really hard to
invest in like a five or ten or even a
two year time horizon like you might in
a
for-profit company so um i think the
headline in all
this is that nonprofits philanthropy
these are really valuable places to work
they're trade-offs and one of the
trade-offs is that it can feel really
sloggy and it's more of a slow burn than
uh than most of the time than
in for-profits so do you see yourself we
talked about this idea
of non-linear career pathways do you see
yourself going back to the
to the sort of the business sector and
the for-profit sector or is this
something that you're really passionate
about that you see yourself going
forever yeah i i
i i'm not idealist sorry i'm not an
ideologue about any particular
um organization of a of a an entity like
you know some companies are great as
for-profits and nonprofits that are
great
i believe in importance in the role of
government and so my hope and
maybe to end the conversation where we
where we started um
you know i think i've learned about
myself that i love having a portfolio of
things i work on and so
i you know i would be surprised although
not shocked if i
um if you know i never spend 10 or 15 or
20 years on one thing in my career
um it's just not exactly who i am or not
who i've been although we all can change
and
one thing i like to share with people
who are thinking about their own careers
in career trajectories is that that's
okay like i think
for me i felt that that was not okay for
a while and um i was talking to a mentor
of mine and
he basically asked like have you ever
considered that this is okay like this
is not a problem to solve but maybe
um but maybe it's not around
totally exactly well put um so um yeah
if anyone's listening to this who's
thinking about their own career and
career design like um you know
maybe look at the patterns that you've
created in your early career and think
critically about you know if you've
problematized them is this actually a
problem
and how might if it feels like a problem
how might i make it not a problem and
sometimes that can be i think liberating
definitely no no i love it you know we
have just about a minute and a half left
and
i have so many more questions but i have
the most important one and i'm going to
put you on the spot so i apologize in
advance
uh i'd love for you to tell me three
words that would be describe yourself
that you would best describe yourself or
that one of your co-founders would
describe you or andrew ing would
describe you as
oh man um okay uh
probably um curious
uh earnest very earnest
and uh neurotic like a good
a good jewish a good jewish guy very
neurotic
i love it does it help with business
sometimes uh it creates a lot of mental
angst that sometimes helps i suppose
yeah i love it eli thank you so much for
the time thank you so much for the
inspiration
and i mean this non-linear path that
you're talking about i think it's
something that's really
it's really important i had this really
interesting talk with alyssa rapp
who's a gsb literature and so i talked
with her a while back and uh
i believe we already by the time this
airs that
her video will already be published and
one of the most interesting things that
she was talking about was her non-linear
path that she got from that she saw her
mother go through
and and and today really we have this
privilege and
you know especially that we get to go to
these really great institutions and we
get to
harness all these different skill sets
it's almost
a waste not to go and try to put our
feet in
to dive into different waters and to
test different fields and see where we
can make an impact
uh on various sectors not just one
well put yeah well today it's been a
pleasure thanks so much and uh
yeah great great to be here thank you
and we'll we'll need to catch up over a
beer
when i'm back in palo alto and this
whole covert thing is over
beautiful let's do it well yeah take
care thanks so much
[Music]
you